The joe rogan experience,
which by the way,
did you just see this new fucking thing that they're going to release the
Facebook phone?
No,
the Samsung is going to release something called the Galaxy Mega.
No.
Holy Shit,
dude.
It's six inches.
It's like there's two versions of it.
There's a 5.8 inch and a 6.3 inch.
You're like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
That's not a phone.
What am I going to do it?
That's,
that's,
that's a crazy thing.
I don't know what that is.
I Dunno what that is.
That's some cross crossover world thing that you have to have a man first to
carry that around.
Or a woman and woman would be excellent.
If I was a girl and I had a bag,
you know,
girls are allowed to carry purses,
which is so awesome.
You know,
there's one thing they have got us with,
with this society,
not women,
but the societies got us whipped with this stupid idea that somehow or another,
a man's on a lot of carry a purse.
You don't record the Robin Hood days.
Those mother fuckers had shoulder bags.
Okay.
You're allowed to wear a backpack.
I'm wearing a backpack like I'm a fucking school kid.
Went through to two.
Nobody gives me a hard time with it,
but if I wear a fanny pack,
they will look at me like someone,
God damn freaking nature.
I'll tell you folks,
we got to take back the fanny packs.
Go to take back the fanny pack and maybe even introduce a fucking purse.
Huh?
How about them apples?
Get yourself a purse,
boys.
Fuck it.
Yeah,
you got a little man purse.
There's nothing wrong with that man.
The idea that there's something somehow or another feminine or weak about
carrying around a bag is a perplexing aspect of this society.
Ladies and gentlemen,
it doesn't make any sense.
We are allowed to carry certain bags.
If you're carrying like a military style Duffel bag,
that's fine,
but you're not allowed to have a purse.
You can't go through the airport with a purse.
Dudes will laugh at you.
Dudes with backpacks,
carrying duffle bags will laugh at you.
If you've got a purse,
we'll give you this guy with his fucking purse.
What is that?
A purse,
Bro.
You go to fucking prison.
What is that difference between the fucking person?
A backpack?
What's going on here?
Come on,
man.
A duffel bags.
Okay.
And I can't have a fucking purse.
This is nonsense.
We have subjected ourselves to some nonsense that we just have accepted over the
years and now it's become culture and Brian Red Bank.
God bless you for breaking the mold,
young man.
God bless you.
Keep my zantax.
Keep your antech.
What does antiques,
but is that I have from drinking too much heartburn medicine.
You take heartburn medicine.
Yeah.
Oh Dude.
Silly Bitch.